all right you know how you have memories
of a movie being good from your past
then you watch it it doesn't quite hold
up your like as a bummer I should've
left that nostalgia i watch the fly
recently i have fond memories of the fly
being awesome turns out the fly is still
awesome so i want to talk about the
flies let's talk about it
[Music]
the fly so the fly is directed by David
Cronenberg it stars Jeff Goldblum as
scientist Seth Brundle Seth Brundle is
working on something is something
spectacular what is it will the invites
of journalists played by Geena Davis
over to his loft to check it out he's
working on teleportation ain't that
great did teleports matter from one pod
to another pod it's gonna change the
world and he has a few kinks to work out
but he works him out and he does it on
himself which probably is not smart and
a housefly gets in the pod with him the
computers like I don't know how all
right I'll just genetically fuse them
together now we have a monster movie
kind of it's the drama really and this
one of the things I love about the fly
it's not just a monster movie for the
second monster movie all right so the
fly and the thing are both in the
recesses of the 80s when they made
horror movies perfectly at least those
two are honestly they're perfect they
don't need to be remade ever it's like
never remake the thing or the thing that
came out a few years ago was a prequel
so there's leniency there and for what
it was I enjoyed that but they will
never make the fly as good as the 1986
Cronenberg fly this is just so
fascinating as a character movie really
I mean Jeff Goldblum is charmingly dorky
as he usually it always is and it really
is he just had good intentions with this
thing that went horribly wrong and at
first he's all like super strong he has
stamina he's like yeah I feel better
than I've ever felt in my life and he
just no man you're like it's called the
fly I know the premise of the fly this
axe is gonna drop hard and it does and
there's a price to pay for that [ __ ]
back the next time you see him it's been
some time and he's all like crippled up
and he's gross looking he's walking with
crutches I mean he's a shell of the man
he was but he sits the decline that I
love that only is Brundle flies makeup
fantastic in this movie when his ear
starts falling off and his teeth come
out you just buy it it's just it would
be CGI now but it wasn't back then it's
just something a little more gross about
an actual prop ear falling off of
someone's head or their teeth coming out
the fly is a great transformation movie
I love it when someone sequentially just
every scene you see him in a little more
change she's a little more degraded he's
a little more fly and really it's that
the hero and the villain it's the same
person
grundles is likable nice dude and in the
end he is still a victim because I'm
like dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde where dr.
Jekyll was a good guy and mr. Hyde was
really the same physical person but he
was a completely different personality
there come
part metallized you feel like dr. Jekyll
isn't as accountable for mr. highs
actions as Seth Brundle is for his own
but you know it's him the more he
becomes more insect the less Seth
Brundle he is so in that he is a victim
but the line is so blurred you don't
know where one ends and the other begins
it's so subtle is fantastic it's like
quintessential great monster movie at
that point yeah I love my horror movies
and slasher films for what they are I
really do there's something about the
fly it's a drama it's a character drama
it's a sci-fi movie it's a horror movie
it's a monster movie it blends all these
elements perfectly in a way I really
can't think that I've seen since the fly
if you know one that's done it well -
hey comment below man love to hear it
even Jeff Goldblum's acting is perfect
for a fly just he's neurotic like you
say where he's like she turned her into
a thigh 185-pound fly just like he has
these weird tics and mannerisms where
like I feel like you're becoming a
skeezy little turkey ass fly person like
if there was a fly human-sized that
should and would be terrifying because
insects are not the kindest things ever
just so happens that we are so much
bigger than them that if we were on
their scale and they were a little above
us in the food chain we should fear we
should be afraid we should be very
afraid
so knowing that Seth Brundle is becoming
a human-sized fly you're just like more
and more he's becoming a dick and more
and more it's it really is one of the
few movies that actually invokes fear
from me guys in the end the fly is
sci-fi horror perfection it really is in
a movie about hey he's our good guy he's
our hero who's slowly turning into
something horrific physically and
mentally it's just it's done the best
here that I've ever seen guys seriously
for Halloween if you're having a movie
fest with your friends watch the fly no
it's not conventional it's not like
Friday the 13th or scream or Nightmare
on Elm Street trick-or-treat what people
usually watch on Halloween but it really
is a cool horror transformation monster
movie with depth that you really don't
see these days I will say the fly is
awesome tacular
alright guys in the 1986 the fly have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]